Wow new meme this is happening it's it's
happening holy [ __ ] there's gonna be the
coolest movie of 2018 so New Mutants we
have a trailer now we have it all again
it's actually the second trailer
officially the first for this go-around
for this attempt at releasing the movie
new meetings is a movie that's set in
the x-men universe we kind of executed
as a horror movie think house on Haunted
Hill but with mutant powers or a thing
of house on Haunted Hill because of
mutant powers which was amazing and then
didn't happen and then even Maisie
Williams was like I don't know daaaad it
was dead thought it was canceled thought
it was never gonna see the light of that
and then we have a trailer today so
that's we're talking about the trailer
now looks like it did before I mean it
looks like a cool premise I think that
is a very interesting take on mutant
powers because some of those mutant
powers damn scary
so what lends itself to that
claustrophobic creepy hospital house on
Haunted Hill is a sad tone it's like
it's the reverse xavius man ships like
xavier smashing is heaven this is hell
with the mutant power so like obviously
and [ __ ] it's like don't worry the
schuster power you're gifted yeah [ __ ]
that power then any stuff gets me
interested it's like they're being
tormented in this hospital no like we
need to fight our way out it was a part
of me it's like wait now that it's
coming out under Disney because Disney
bought Fox is it gonna be Disney Plus
MCU friendly I hear it's not I hear it's
still gonna be the creep fest that it
was it was supposed to be supposed to be
write it alright alright
don't ask questions Jeremy you have a
phone research Oh pg-13 that will damn
it
and it always was gonna be pg-13 I guess
because that's from that's from 2018
alright well let me in pg-13 I guess we
can't blame the fact that Disney by Fox
and that's why because that's not why
what do you think I don't know who these
characters are I imagine they're Nate
are they named x-men characters I don't
know I don't know who they are I mean if
someone said the names maybe I would be
like oh yeah this is where I find out I
did have their HeroClix and I just
didn't know that always happens when you
play games or you have trading card I
mean who trading cards going back but
when I revisit my collection of hero
clerks I'm like whoa I know that
character now I didn't before
now there's super famous they're super
well known but the thing I love most
about this is what I've loved about the
x-men movies recently that I've liked is
that they don't feel like x-men movies
because they're kind of not x-men movies
really I'm kind of talking about Logan
Logan feels like a different kind of
thing other than x-men it just takes
place in that x-men universe and that's
amazing and the x-men universe
completely lends itself to that so it
looks good it's a cool take on the x-men
universe a logical one because sometimes
those powers even if I had one of the
cool powers the ones that weren't dead
as frightening like in this movie I'd
still freak out if I could freeze things
to be like huh x-men always just kind of
you know they roll with it unless you're
rogue and you're kissing your boyfriend
when you're in high school and you know
you take part of his soul it's on the
bed he's in a coma that's like the only
time I've ever seen anyone truly freak
out with an x-men power so this seems
like that but times 100 so this is kind
of a simple video the fact that I'm like
oh please happening cool because I
didn't think it would ever crazy a scene
in the trailers when the camera was
panning around that big undead rotting
corpse of a zombie standing there you
see that saying yeah you know that scene
right there a kid a kid Fox gave us some
good times all right so the new trailer
to New Mutants saying it's gonna come
out this year have you seen it what you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]